all right amber welcome back
hi I think that's better couple months
right yeah as soon as you months so
what's what's been going on
well still still vague but a lot of
things have changed after seeing the
other the other people on the shows I
learned a lot let my stories not that my
life wasn't that bad you know
I just made bad choices so now I have
another thought process now I at the
time was a kid it was the worst thing
but now as an adult and you're all these
other stories and I'm just like thank
God thankful I mean there's a lot of
girls that work Figg do you think they
all are out there and maybe no one's
really aware of other people's I see
that 90 probably 90% of the women out
there I'm fake are victims of childhood
trauma and no one else clue I was
talking to a couple other girls and they
were like I would say the same thing but
it was that it at it I was like whoa
okay so it made me think like okay amber
your life wasn't that bad get it
together stop messing around so I hoped
oh now am i working I probably won't see
only 25% 25% of the people that was seen
before I don't like it any longer
I see the badness in it the disrespect
things how there's other ways to make
money there's other ways to get by I've
learned that from watching the videos
and about talking to them and the girls
a lot of people a lot of my friends were
like whoa I didn't know that that's what
happened to you can tell me some more
about it so as I tell them more they're
like yeah I have that choice I'd make
that choice to family survival or not to
survive so I got like a lot of like okay
paddlin Baxter making the decision to
survive but sent her at the comments and
a lot of comments were like no one has
right through that to you no one should
do that to you no one should do that see
anyone but I didn't know I thought it
was just part of the work for the job
so now I've gotta get together I gotta
make changes I want to be the best
person I could be not the best working
girl I could be and that's where I was
at it do you want to go where quick
quick quick
no it's steady since they say steady so
you're working less weigh less I'm
afraid to work here's some of these
girls story about what happened to them
on dates mines was nothing like I said I
didn't get hurt some of these girls if
you see the tapes they're probably just
figured I don't couple scratches couple
of battle wounds but I got to get out of
here before I become - probably just
figured I lost a tooth the other day on
a date and I was like okay this is not
okay I was with a man that was at been a
a vet been in Afghanistan some other
people were fighting outside the room
and they like he had a flashback
I guess PTSD and he punched me elbowed
me and we're at that point we're both
are trying to get out of the room at the
same time because whatever he saw I felt
was coming and he knew it was coming so
it was like let's get out here
but yeah I'm missing a tooth now that's
it for me I'm done now they're like a
jack-o'-lantern I'm finished so I'm
going back to school online classes
that's a moment good for you that's
sooner than I thought listener hear I
hear so many girls at all these horrific
stories of things have happened to them
while they're working on the street and
[Music]
my reaction I don't say anything but my
thoughts are like well that that's a
that's a sign that you should never ever
do that it's too dangerous
right but it's like but they all go back
it's a red flag that's a red flag and
right that you should not do that again
yeah but these girls do it for years and
decades well sometimes it's endless
cycle okay you stopped joining now what
are you gonna do how you gonna eat
we're gonna go some people this is for
some women and some
this is the only thing they know to get
to the next stage in their life whether
it be eating the Siravo
you know suppose our three survival
skills as humans so it's hard there's no
resources anyway you're trapped in this
this life you don't know how to even get
out of it you don't know if you should
what should you say
who should you go to there's no
resources at all
so you stays to stay with what they know
because they know that they do this
don't get fed and they get addicted to
the fast money a lot it's a big thing
because I um the first time I said I'm
dying was just uh a few years ago
I cried I cried like I I lost some
parents because here it is now now what
I do I'm bored what I do I hear I'm like
thinking about what where what I could
be doing at this time of day how much
money I might have and I don't have it
it was like losing a family member the
decision to step off with a check it's
addicting if this becomes your life your
family stands fifteen years all your is
the same as the building a relationship
in a family you have to walk you lose
your kid or you this is a 15 year old
something you're feeling it and I
definitely feel felt it that last time
but this time I got a plan and gotta
make some plans something different
positive thinking motivates just talk to
someone anyone you need to replace it
with something yeah after you because
this is there like Bordeaux now what I
do gets thinking in your head and your
best think is what got you in the
situation you're in
so you shouldn't maybe follow that I
think there are very few addicts or
alcoholics or whatever you can but you
Alex you name it who just decided to
quit and that was it they found
something else that fills that void yeah
they find other things to fill that void
or they just stop using but there's
still that mindset of an addict and they
take the next thing and they do it just
the same way as they did using yeah
hopefully you'd find it something
healthier well I'm going to school so
I'm hoping that the books and the
studying and you know focusing on my
grades and Michael tests that that's
gonna pass that time that boring that
bored of a hat hat so yeah school it's
almost
because I've heard so many stories with
addicts with with sex workers with gang
members all kinds of people it's almost
like the perception the idea that the
street life is cool or doing drugs is
cool right or being in a gang is cool
it's almost like that that's the
thinking that needs to change right and
something like being responsible human
being that's that's upstanding and has a
job and went to school and got and
achieve something that needs to be seen
as cool again well as it did maybe back
in the 60s fifties
yeah well see you getting best fifties
and sixties a lot of things are in
changed we all know why they're gonna
change we if you don't know anything
because that's what your parent your
grandma did or that's what your grandpa
dad or your mom dad your dad did
gangbang or did drugs or just do like it
just seemed like fun we ran outside
looking in it does like to see my cool
she leaves she comes Michael $600 but
you have no idea what it took to get
that $600 and I'm not gonna tell you
said I had to do this and that or that I
have to you know the worst case scenario
had it happen I'm gonna glamorize it
like hey I got this morning let's get
high or just whatever shop but you know
I'm not an idea what that says to get it
get everything drinking game banging of
working the streets it's going fight
from television rap magazines is it's
the [ __ ] there's a bit cool isn't it so
what you do use drugs these look sweet
you your game member you you rap me
right you know your street worker you
get that money that's what we were
taught and that's what the television
shows us that's what society shows us
but once you get into a lifestyle you're
like whoa I didn't know that I was gonna
get raped when I start working the
streets I know that no one told me that
they just said Oh get that money have
fun you know no one said hey girl more
likely you're gonna be getting raped if
someone was told me that I was 16 years
old
oh no I would have found another job
something different but I didn't know I
was thinking it was cool because my
friend of the time she would
hundreds you were gone 30 minutes 600 oh
yeah I could do that I can learn to like
that that's what you do
gang banging oh man I got this lower I
got the speeches I got you know I got
what I want
but you didn't know he hadn't knock off
a couple people you know he has to go in
to harmful sperm to people yes sell
drugs and put drugs in neighborhood
that's I got that or just slide to it's
all misconception yeah almost like our
perception of what is cool needs to
change yeah what's that
definitely has to change a lot of things
have to change
because what I see is there's so many
self-destructive paths that are seen as
cool and you've got a whole support
system saying yeah that's cool and it's
not right
so is that sad to say ah ah it takes you
down you go from looking like a beauty
queen to the we Toto fein no matter what
in 90 days yeah not cool
that's what we need to show like this
lights a channel that's what the channel
shows guess what all of these people
were once like you what it's like you on
TV were all out there but this is what's
gonna happen it's not can't happen this
is what's gonna happen if you take these
breath this route it makes these choices
it's not if it's gonna it's gonna happen
you're gonna lose your life out here
you're getting stabbed or gonna get
raped or you're gonna Rob it is going to
happen now had I seen a magazine call
it's going to happen a lot these of
achiever is like different you know a
lot of things we different even if you
so come they have what scared straight
for kids and that of ahead of them
criminal issues it's gonna present a
scared straight we need to start doing
that with some of these well isn't this
channel kind of does you know first
graders cuz now you got to start way
younger then you start when I was a kid
we started when I was nine by nine I'm
pregnant already twice never tell me a
young kid watching a bunch of these
videos hi hey and seeing the end result
yeah this is an I mean if you can't put
two and two together then then your way
to you where do you do that next update
with the death date on there you know
this is
of day of day death yeah you know if
anything happens I think I got one of
those coming up just shot it allows you
just died across the street from my
studio how much we got I think the rumor
the rumors is dead but we're talking to
you for a calf calf I'm a good friend of
mine Mary Jo thank you so much for
coming in again thank you for having me
good luck home where you going thank you
it sounds great thanks thank you okay I
wanted to come back after school like
next semester
you